- Ohhhh, how's this not cat food?
- BuzzFeed presents SPAM Taste Test
- Spam was invented in 1937,
and was a popular ration
for allied troops during World War II.
- Bacon Spam? That's a way to get
into anybody's heart, right?
- You ready?
- I'm ready.
- You want to do the honors?
- Sure.
- Oh.
(chuckling)
- It knows.
- It does smell like bacon though.
- That's the thing with Spam.
You gotta sorta you gotta
wean it out a little bit.
- It's very cuttable.
- So it's always like
sort of stored in its own
congealed fat, which is very fun.
- Go.
How was it?
- It is a salt slam in your face.
- It tastes like ham, but
they did the chewing for you.
- Did you like it?
- No, I'm regretting this.
- I would like some more, yes please.
- [Voiceover] Tocino.
- That's a, what is that?
- But I'm trying to
figure out what tocino is.
- I think torcino is,
like, pork belly maybe.
- Let's get in it.
- Tangy.
Mine's really tangy.
- Why is it sweet?
- It's like candied flesh.
- Oh, it's amazing.
- It's great.
I can eat this all day.
- The flavor of that one isn't as bad.
- Blowin' my mind over here.
And it's orange?
That's fun.
- [Voiceover] Hot and spicy.
- It is red.
- Do you like spicy things?
- I do.
- You do?
- I do, but I feel like I won't like this.
- That's a spicy meat paste.
- You're gonna cry about it?
- No.
- This can go away.
- [Voiceover] Hickory smoke, oh.
- [Voiceover] Alright.
- You want this whole thing, don't you?
- That might be too much.
- Ready?
- Yes, nom, nom, nom.
- Oh no.
- There's something
weird at the end of it.
Like it's like an after taste.
- It's just salt and smoke.
- Eeeww, it gets so bad
throughout
- Elch.
- Spam's a weird animal.
- [Voiceover] Black pepper.
- Click! Boom!
- Bam!
- Whoa!
- Psh!
- It smells like a vienna sausages.
- It does.
- It's so much pepper.
- Uh, that's how much pepper it is.
- [Voiceover] Turkey.
- Wait a minute, is it actually turkey?
- Bird meat is very
different than mammal meat.
- Smells turkey-ish.
- Not the worst.
- Uh-uh.
- It's fine.
- No, it's not.
- I had no idea there was
more than one kind of Spam.
- I actually loved most of it.
Um, I think it's pretty great.
- I'd never eaten Spam before.
Now I'm team Spam.
- There's a sweetness in
that it was both our firsts,
but we know it's not right for us.
We're gonna move along.
- On the side it says,
"Fully cooked. Ready to eat cold or hot.
But, serve warm and enjoy."
Serve cold and it's fine.
BuzzFeed presents SPAM Taste Test